ein forschungsteam aus den usa meldet
einen entscheidenden durchbruch beim bau
künstlicher muskeln aus kunststoff
pflanzenöl und elektroden künstliche
muskeln herzustellen ist eine der
größten herausforderungen beim
roboterbauer denn in zukunft sollen
roboter für viele anwendungen flexibel
sein und eben aus diesem grund
hauptsächlich aus weichen materialien
bestehen wie funktionieren diese
künstlichen muskeln was können sie
wirklich und in welchen bereichen können
sie eingesetzt werden jetzt ein klick
zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
mit künstlichen muskeln könnte man nicht
nur körper ähnliche prothesen bauen
sondern sie dienen auch als grundlage
für die sogenannten soft robots damit
sind roboter gemeint die aus weichen
materialien bestehen und so zahlreiche
besondere aufgaben erfüllen könnten
beispielsweise wäre es ihnen aufgrund
ihrer flexibilität möglich bei
rettungsaktionen durch geröll und schutt
zu den verschütteten zu kommen
geschmeidig wie ein oktopus eine
entwicklung genau solcher künstlicher
muskeln also für soft roberts ist jetzt
einem forschungsteam aus den usa
gelungen und die wissenschafts community
bezeichnet das als echten durchbruch die
hydraulisch verstärkten selbstheilenden
elektrostatischen künstlichen muskeln
bestehend aus elektroden kunststoff und
pflanzenöl konkret aus elastischen
kunststoffen die wieder in ihre
ursprüngliche form zurückfinden auch
elastomere genannt andere wiederum aus
flexiblen dünnen polymer plastikfolien
die mit isolierenden flüssigkeiten
gewillt sind wie in pflanzenöl
so entsteht ein hydraulisches element
beschichtet mit gel das sehr dehnbar ist
und elektrische ladungen leitet dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher christoph
kepplinger setzt man das ganze unter
spannung baut sich ein elektrisches feld
auf dass die verschiedenen schichten
durchdringt und eine elektrostatische
kraft auf die flüssigkeit aussieht so
wird die hülle performt und es entstehen
bewegung die sehr unsere
muskelbewegungen nl
bezüglich der energieeffizienz und der
geschwindigkeit der kontraktion also
hier so zusammenziehen übertreffen sie
aber sogar biologische muskeln oder sind
zumindest mit ihnen auf einem level und
sie können schon echt viel die
künstlichen muskeln sind in der lage
weiche gegenstände wie etwa rohe eier
vorsichtig anzuheben
genauso gut können sie aber auch mehrere
kilogramm in die luft stemmen oder sehr
sehr schnelle bewegungen ausführen
selbst wenn elektrische durchschläge
passieren also wenn irgendwas hier in
kurzen wenn es den gibt es diesen
vergleich zu den bisherigen entwickelten
künstlichen muskeln kein drama denn die
isolierenden flüssigkeiten verteilen
sich danach neu und heilen sich selbst
der nächste schritt soll sein dass dies
auch auf der außenfläche möglich wird
dass sich also auch die außen folien
nach
sein oder ähnlichem selbst reparieren
ein weiterer pluspunkt die
herstellungsverfahren und benötigten
materialien sind easy und preiswert
herzustellen
die erzeugung der elemente kostet nur
etwa zehn cent erst ende letzten jahres
hatten amerikanische kolleginnen und
kollegen einen künstlichen muskel mit
superkräften entwickelt nach angaben des
forschungsteams des m und der harvard
university könne er das 1000 fache
seines eigengewichts heben und auch er
seit preis günstig in der herstellung
nicht mehr als einen dollar sei ihr zu
kalkulieren dieser muskel ist allerdings
anders aufgebaut erst besteht aus einer
kammer mit einem inneren skelett aus
kunststoff und die art und weise wie die
kamera gefaltet wird entscheidet darüber
welche bewegungen der muskel ausführt
denn das skelett befindet sich in einer
kammer gefüllt mit einer flüssigkeit
oder luft die wird herausgeputzt so dass
ein unterdruck entsteht so wird die
bewegung hervorgerufen
so sind diese muskeln extrem leicht
zunehmen aber sehr stark und vielseitig
einsetzbar ein 2,6 gramm schwerer muskel
könne drei kilogramm annehmen dass
verglichen die wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftler mit einer ente die ein
auto stimmt durch diese erkenntnisse
erhoffen sich die forschungsteams fast
jeden roboter für jede aufgabe
konstruieren zu können die roboter der
zukunft verstehen also nicht mehr aus
blech sondern können ihre gestalt
verändern und sind biegsam und er kennt
es sich denken diese eigenschaften
lassen sie so vielfältige aufgaben
übernehmen soft roberts können aber
nicht nur pakete im lager packen sondern
eben auch klar auch auf kleinsten teilen
in kugelschreiber zusammensetzen
ihre hände sind weich und raum und das
ermöglicht ihnen sowohl eine tomate ganz
vorsichtig als auch eine rutschige
plastikverpackung entsprechend zu packen
ob das wieder ein schritt zur
technologischen singularität ist also
dem zeitpunkt an dem die technologie den
menschen überholt ja ob es diesem
zeitpunkt gegeben wird und ob er je
erreicht wird hierbei clixoom bleiben
wir dran wenn er kein video dazu und zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann endet mich bei whatsapp ganz
verpasst ihr kein video was passieren
würde wenn ihr euch hier auf die abo box
verlassen würde und zudem über whatsapp
erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social
media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht
die genau die glocke vergessen und hier
geht es weiter mit einem weiteren video
über sensationelle entwicklungen in der
robotik bis dann bleibt dran